you look at like a situation with rick
rubin
he's out i had to set up microphones in
front of him
and just that stress the anxiety he
knows a lot about microphones what'd he
say which i really loved he's like how
close
do you like
the microphone to be
it's like that's a very rick rubin kind
of thing right that the details really
matter yeah the details really matter
right down to your relationship to the
microphone right yeah distance and
whether or not it brings out the timbre
in your voice but of course that's what
he does he produces music but he also
said like you know he is the
professional
he said
how close do you like it to be and he
said it with the gentleness where i had
like an existential crisis where i don't
i don't know i
he gave me so much like
wow like he made me feel like an artist
like that the microphone
uh distance is a decision you're
supposed to make well i have to say and
this has actually come up in some of our
conversations about you i mean you are
you are an artist and actually joe rogan
once i heard him talking about
podcasting and the fact that he's always
trying to get better at it you know and
he described podcasting at one moment as
an art right and it is it's a certain
medium of communication and there's a
cadence and a rhythm that um when it's
working it really can facilitate the
transfer of information when it's not it
doesn't i mean obviously joe just being
himself has tapped into that cadence
that allows and it's made so many people
excited to hear him talk well in his
case and in general i think part of the
art is uh refusing the world as you get
a bigger audience
change who you are there's one quote
that i've seen out there where he says
you know i'm like the talking about
himself he says you know i'm like the
fish that got through the net there's no
stage version of me right how he is
in person is how he is uh you know out
in the world and of course there's
nuance to his life right and his
different um relationships of course but
it's true i mean we've had the you know
the great fortune of spending time with
him out away from the microphones so to
speak
joe is joe
so can you speak to your that process
you mentioned the walking and the
talking to yourself because that's
fascinating yeah i try and
do a couple of things um
first of all i when i was a kid i had a
little bit of a grunting tick
uh when i was five or six um i would
feel this build-up of tension in my
throat
and i would do this grunting tick if i
get very tired i start to do it still we
actually know that this is related to
these basal ganglia circuits for go
no-go you've got an accelerator and a
break basically in your neural circuitry
and um kids with turrets in ocd
the brake doesn't work quite as well and
so one thing that happens is if i wake
up in the morning and i'm especially if
i'm well rested
well if i'm not well rested i do a
hypnosis or yoga nidra in order to
recover my sleep that works really well
but then once i'm into the process of
preparing the podcast
i've already gone through my notes i
know what i want to say more or less in
a kind of general contour and then i
take a walk
and i
i try to so no phone with me and i try
to assess
whether or not my energy is too high or
too low for podcasting because when you
podcast as you know
you have to punch out a lot of material
but then there's times when you really
need to slow down and emphasize and
articulate
and so
what i do
this is i don't i've never revealed this
what i do actually is i will recite the
lyrics of songs for about 10 minutes
um songs i love while i walk out loud it
calms you and focuses you what does it
do i think it gets my vocal cords
warmed up and it also do you sing or
speak them i often sing them
and unfortunately nobody hears and as i
do this i start to evaluate whether or
not i'm straining to get the words out
or whether or not i'm straining
to
make them slow enough so that i can
articulate them
so there are days when i have so much
energy
that i
i'm trying to speak faster than i should
in order to articulate properly there
are other days when i'm tired and i
can't sort of keep up with my thoughts
and so what i try and do is assess that
and then adjust the transmission the rpm
so to speak for instance i can speak
very quickly and then i can slow down so
i can change the cadence of my voice and
when you teach in the classroom you
learn as you know because you're an
excellent teacher i've watched your
lectures in the classroom as you teach
in the classroom when you want to slow
down
every teacher knows you turn to the
whiteboard or chalkboard and you start
writing right it gives you a break and
then you turn around and you fire back
the kind of machine gun fire of of
information and then you slow down or
you underline something when you podcast
you don't have that opportunity right
there are no visuals in my podcast so
what i try and do is always
get my voice warmed up and make sure
that i'm thinking and speaking at
approximately the same rate
and then i also do this thing as i put
my vision into panoramic vision when i
walk which is very calming
and then i actually start to remind
myself of the purpose of podcasting this
sounds very mission statement e but you
asked what i do
i i remind myself first
and foremost that what i want to
communicate what i want to come through
is the beauty and utility of biology
and i only feel comfortable saying the
word beauty publicly now
about science things thanks to you
because uh i i think love and beauty
yeah life
love and beauty dr andrew humerman love
and beauty um but also darkness and
hatred and uh if you're talking about
the lex friedman podcast you have to
adjust you have to address the shadow
also the shadow side but i think about
the i want to communicate the
the beauty and utility of biology and
then i i check my
my emotional state i want to make sure
that i'm not angry about anything
and certainly if i am that i'm going to
set it aside for the podcast because
that's not a place for for my whatever i
might be dealing with i also really
start to feel into the parts of the
research and the papers i found that i
really love because that's the part of
me that
i i like the most frankly um
and
on the podcast if there's a paper like
for instance we have a paper excuse me a
podcast coming out soon about um heat as
a tool you know sauna but some other
things and in researching this i learned
so much about
these heat shock proteins and the use of
sauna in finland for increasing growth
hormone but also for the treatment of
mental illness and i realized i i fell
in love with this literature it's just a
beautiful literature these people are
true pioneers for doing this work now
everyone's into sauna but this was 20
years ago the way the experiments were
done were amazing with all these finnish
people with thermocouples up there
rectum to measure temperature swimming
in pools it's hilarious and great and so
i start to think about i think
you know i just start to really access
my love of the work and then when we
finally sit down
meaning my producer rob and i and record
i just sort of want to just bask in in
sharing it just like the little version
of me when i was six or seven i used to
spend all weekend reading the
encyclopedia guinness book of world
records making my mother drive me places
to introduce me to i had this obsession
with trapping animals when i was a kid
meet these people and then on monday i
would insist on giving a lecture in
class just as a little kid so that's
basically what it is i just try and
access that
that childlike energy and um so i want
to be clear
the goal is always to make the
information
interesting clear
and actionable and if it's also
surprising then then that's a bonus but
that's basically the process but yeah
i'm i'm singing and talking and and
getting into state
and i used to feel very sheepish about
sharing any of this it's the first time
i've ever shared it out loud but but
rick was the one who encouraged me to
find a process that works and continue
to develop that process and not let
anything get near that process people in
my personal life know this and when it's
time it's like i don't care what else is
going on on i'm i'm moving into that
brain state and there's probably a
process like that for anything that you
do in life that you take seriously so
the people that have perfected this is
athletes like if olympic level athletes
they have to have a process like this
you know i think tiger woods actually
was
taught self-hypnosis quite young
and used self-hypnosis often during his
tournaments sometimes to great
uh success and other times less so is
there other
places in life
that you use
kind of a protocol like a mental
protocol to get ready
many of the best areas of life are their
own form of hypnosis right um you know
that you're in hypnosis if for instance
you're in a movie and something happens
and you feel the emotional lift
without being self-conscious about it um
yes i think that um
one thing that we've tried to do in our
house is around meal times to try and
set a state
that food isn't just something that we
just throw down our throats and i'm
fortunate that you know my partner cooks
really well and so i try and give her
the space to do that and that's a whole
thing of her getting into state and then
for the cooking though for the cooking
preparation i can just see it i just see
the way she approaches the whole thing
and the the pleasure in serving it and
and i'm an eater not a cooker um
but both are important roles
you could be a very good eater like
there's something about is there
anything better in this world than that
feeling especially if it's a family
getting around a table
just the warmth of that
i don't know the
it's like
the cold outside of the the cruel world
cannot touch you in this place that
you've returned to and if uh
i mean did you grow up eating meals as a
family yeah yeah i mean sitting down no
television
no well i didn't really have television
period uh
uh outside of meals
so most of my time was spent
um
you know like a stray cat
uh outdoors just running around
playing soccer imagine you in this like
dirt or concrete lot between two very
high-rise buildings playing soccer yeah
in uh in like athletic gear that you
only see in eastern europe you know how
like you come to the states and people
wear their athletic gear you go to
europe and you see
maybe it's the soccer culture yeah but
you see athletic gear that you just
don't see anywhere else that's
interesting i mean i
we grew up pretty poor so
first of all i was always wearing my
who's an older brother brother's clothes
and they were like
old
uh
like my favorite things were american
things that i didn't understand it would
be like a pepsi shirt or something and
it was just that was the gear and it was
like too large for me but i thought i
was the coolest person ever just wearing
this fancy like kanye
like type of fashion yeah there's
something about i feel like in in
eastern europe they wear athletic gear
where like the guys just like zip up
yeah no that's like fancy stuff that's a
few like those are the cool kids i see
like the cool soccer players uh football
players that uh
like they were in a league of some kind
so they would get uniforms or like or
they somehow
i always thought anyone who had anything
nice
had to do something really bad to get it
that was my way that's the view of the
world because like um
like i guess i didn't understand
how it's it's possible to be rich
because most of us were surrounded by
people who were poor and that life was
beautiful and simple it's like why do
you escape that life but you still
admire the the cool like uh
when we got mcdonald's it was like
what kind of world
does this place come from like who
invented this
this it's a fascinating view from a
child's perspective of like of
capitalism essentially yeah
but the fact you ate dinner together is
really interesting
my parents divorced when i was an
adolescent so then there was a total
fracture of any family structure but
prior to that we ate dinner together
every night i was expected to know how
to use my knife and fork and you know
it's like a
very um structured thing uh i don't know
if kids do that now
um you know if i ever have kids they're
gonna do that
and certainly um actually on the way
over here i was thinking i was like you
know uh i really want a lot of kids i
want to like a whole litter and um i was
thinking if lex has kids and i have kids
then like then we can
we can like pit them against each other
with jiu jitsu yeah this is my chance at
redemption
uh the long game
right they'll all want to be engineers
or physicists yeah um they won't want to
be biologists um
but but in all seriousness i i look
forward to the day that our our kids uh
play together yeah yeah i think there's
something uh so the family dinner the
ritual of the family dinner like but
also the special occasion dinners like
uh
where there's a little bit more
preparation a little bit more cooking
whether it's on the weekend or for some
holiday
uh in russia it was
a thing that actually i find completely
missing for the most part
in america is there was neighbors there
was a
you broke the walls between families
much more commonly
like there would be kind of regular
characters like a sitcom almost you know
if you watch the sitcom it's never just
the family there's always like other
characters there's bursting in the door
bursting in the door let's start doing
that here just to make you feel at home
just start showing up i know where you
live i think people want to respect uh
like uh you know michael malus lives
next door to me and i think people want
to respect each other's privacy or
something like that and i think
we all get super busy and
you know
like
it's kind of work to do this
uh dinner together
or you know you know if you see it as a
thing that needs to be scheduled it's
work we get busy there's a lot of stuff
going on but if it's part of a ritual a
part of the culture
that the all of those walls get broken
down and then you realize like that's
like later looking back those are the
things you miss it's like that's what
that's what life is about like all the
stupid stuff you're doing in terms of
career whatever
all the busy things those don't matter
what matters
it's the people and yeah in academia you
know
this changed in the last few years of
course um but one of the great joys was
professors will stop by your office or
your lab nobody set up an appointment
there's a guy when i was a professor in
san diego a guy named harvey kearney's
member of the national academy is the
the truly the world's expert in the
evolution of vision and evolution of
brains generally and he would show up in
my lab and he would just start talking
to the students in postdocs and
i mean in a pure encyclopedia uh and
then you at some point you'd say hey
harvey i gotta go and you you kick him
out right or this guy he's a physicist
david klein
david kleinfeld who's so same way
actually david kleinfeld's interesting
one he a student of his
went to on to create the beavis and
butthead cartoon and one of them is
david he's a physics professor now
people can look him up and david's one
of those guys who just walk into your
office he just sit down you just start
talking to you he's and and so there's a
kind of a family feel it's like cheers
or seinfeld or one of those shows where
somebody just walks in and uh yeah i
think you and i both share a love of the
community around things and podcasting
is a little bit more isolated um i
should say for the guest episodes
the preparation is completely different
because it's more conversational and so
there i don't do any of this business of
putting myself into state i just try and
make sure that the guest is
um taken care of and i do list out the
questions i'm gonna ask before but those
i actually really like the interview
episodes far more than i like this doing
the solo ones just psychologically i
mean i just like learning from someone
directly yeah because you asking an
expert about something like sitting here
with you when we recorded the podcast
where you were a guest on the huberman
lab podcast and for the first time and
finally someone was explaining to me the
difference between machine learning
artificial intelligence and all these
other things you know and i'm i've
finally forgiven you for making me cry
about costello on camera uh but because
it helped me move through it but yeah
but in all seriousness the interview
ones are are
a sheer pleasure the solo ones i really
enjoy but they're they're their work
sometimes i think like i'm gonna sweat a
little blood prepping for that
well it's interesting because i do think
prepping for interviews is
having a similar process might be also
very valuable
you